Hi everyone, in this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at Nanite and how it works
with our world building when it comes to using Unreal.
So let's get started.
So Nanite is pretty easy to enable.
But one thing you want to do is make sure what items in your scene because you
may have pulled them in and forgotten to activate Nanite as they come in, as they're
imported.
But you can check that after the fact once you have items in your scene to be able
to convert what's there.
It's easily done by right clicking and going to Nanite and clicking on Nanite and you'll
see automatically and it is now enabled in the objects details for rendering.
So say we want to check it really quick.
Let me show you.
Let's go into Unreal.
So here in Unreal, I can go in here and I can type in with my content folder selected,
I can type in Nanite.
You'll see there's enabled and I want to put equal sign equal sign false.
Now this is going to show me everything in my scene that is not Nanite.
I have a couple a few copies in here and a few other things, but I can simply just
select all of these and convert them to a Nanite object.
That's actually pretty convenient.
Now before we used to have it where you would have to go through the tools and you
could like go through debugging used to be a Nanite debugger, but we decided let's
just keep it simple without another window to deal with.
Simply type it into your search content and you'll be able to find all the Nanite objects.
Now the benefit of using Nanite is the fact that again, using it, it is like virtual
textures, but for polygons.
It only draws what is needed based on my position in the world on a polygon level
versus an old school LOD level.
Basically LOD polygons, you can think of it that way.
That way there's a less of a change in the silhouette, more accuracy and more detail
shows up on the model as you navigate through the world.
So it's pretty awesome and works great.
What you can see here is we have a Nanite object here and he's actually pretty dense.
I ran a few times to make him a little bit denser and using the modeling tools,
I remeshed him, but this dense object is something that Nanite likes and is able
to calculate it.
Now obviously everything has a particular cap or limit if you keep throwing at it.
So you want to be strategic and you can have all your objects high poly.
That's fine, but for some things that may not be seen very often, if you decide to
make them a little lower poly, Nanite's not going to worry about that so much.
You don't have to worry about it like an old school game, so it kind of breaks that
game thinking, but you do have to be careful about really low poly objects.
And what I mean by that, you'll notice I have a piece of geometry here, which is a
simple continuation of that trim sheet.
I just isolated a region and this is a simple polygon in here.
Now if you have a few of these in your scene, that's fine that you will get less
chances of performance hitting you.
You heard me talk about this earlier, but if you have a lot of simple geometry and
you've converted them to a Nanite object, you could run into some problems.
So just keep that in mind.
If you needed to, you could run the modeling tool and remesh this and make it a higher
poly object if you really do need those flat cards or just in your DCC, go and handle
it there and in your DCC, just go ahead and make it so it's a higher poly flat
plane.
And that actually works just fine too.
So I just wanted to point that out.
Just be careful of those things.
Now there are a few things you do need to keep in mind when it comes to working
with Nanite objects.
Let's pick on the trees for a second here.
We'll get back to them later, but if I'm in a scene and I start to zoom out, you
will notice at times at a particular distance, bushes or plants, the tops of the trees
will disappear.
To prevent this from happening, what you want to do is go into that Nanite object
and you want to go ahead and edit it in such a way so that you are turning on preserved
area.
I'm just going to use this guy still since we still have him open.
His options are still the same, even though he's not a tree.
Let's go ahead and double click on this piece of geometry.
Let me go ahead and pull this piece of geometry into our scene.
I'm going to go full screen.
You'll notice if we type in Nanite and make sure we type it, you'll see we have
a preserved area.
Now again, if your trees are disappearing from a distance, you want to turn this on
and Unreal is nice with the pro tips to tell you, Hey man, this is used for foliage
just to help make sure that these surfaces and everything is working cleanly from a
distance.
Now if you go down below, there's another one which is fairly new called max edge length
factor.
This one comes in really handy if you're working with say a construction script and
you're using, say you're making pipes in this particular case.
Let me close this window out for a moment and we're going to go ahead and pick on
this particular piece of geometry and I'm going to double click on the pipes here
in my scene and in here we have, if we type in Nanite again, you'll see that
match that max edge length factor.
It is set to 10.
Now for some reason I leave it at default to be say zero and I hit apply.
You're going to notice a degradation or I should say a lower poly version happened
on your pipes unless you're really up close, then they don't look quite as
bad but as soon as you get a far away, those curves become very lower poly and they don't
look so great.
So we made this edge max edge length factor to be able to edit that.
So I'm going to go in here and type in 10 and I'm going to go ahead and hit apply
changes.
This will make it so it's consistent and if I decide to build out from this particular
construction script that I've created, I can actually have less of an issue with that.
And again, you can play with these numbers.
I have mine at 10 because it's working for these pipes.
You could probably get away with maybe five.
That kind of depends on the complexity of your construction of your items and so forth.
Just keep those things in mind when you're building out how you want them to be represented.
Ten seems to work pretty good for this particular pipe construction.
So just keep those things in mind.
Another thing I want to mention too, when it comes to using Nanite, you do want to
be careful when it comes to combining.
You don't want to combine an object in your scene using some of our merge tools.
Now if you decide, you're like, hey, I want to go in here and merge these actors.
You and say they're already Nanite and you go back in there again and you convert
them to Nanite one more time.
You do got to be careful with that.
If I have, because there can be a double calculation and you may get a performance hit.
You also notice that I have actual rivets here.
Now these little welding rivets, I'm not a plumber, I'm not going to pretend I am,
but these bolts, there you go.
So these bolts in here are pretty low poly.
They're not too low poly, but they're low enough.
And I just brought it in with a model and that's okay.
Nanite's forgiving for very small detail like that.
But if I have a lot of these and I decide like in my scene, I want to merge them and
merge them using the merge tool and convert it to Nanite, you got to be careful because
it's becoming something that wasn't brought in natively, or I should say from the DCC.
You're doing it with Unreal, you're converting Nanite objects, you're merging Nanite objects
and you got to be careful with that.
We go over this more in our optimization for linear content.
But there is an option when it comes to the merge actors, there's an approximate which
allows you to merge Nanite objects, doesn't necessarily mean you should.
So there is a calculation factor that's involved that you got to be careful.
It's better to just have them polyed in.
And as you can see, I can go in here and just kit bash the crap out of things, build
things in pieces, slap them together.
And no one would be the wiser using that whole trim sheet texture that I created for
different aspects and details.
And even simple items like this, these little knobs should be fine.
You just got to be careful.
If you have a lot and you're noticing some performance hit hits happening.
You also have to consider where you're going with your game, whether it's PC, whether
it's console, whether it's a mobile device.
You always want to think smarter as you can when it comes to mobile devices.
You might want to lean more into baking and less of lumen, but all this requires experimentation.
Well that's it with this lecture and the next video we're going to be talking about
blueprints and construction scripts and how to manage your assets as you get them ready
to be calculated for lumen and for Nanite.
Thanks again.